[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute was süßes und
zwar kennt glaube ich schon alle
wir machen kühe auf arabisch männer aber
also wir aus der türkei sie sagen immer
kühner und das ist eine spezialität
bestehend aus teig fäden aus zucker
sirup in der mitte käse jetzt denkt euch
süßes mit käse gepard ja vertrauten ja
soll ich jetzt nicht geht dass vertraut
mir das nicht total lecker und weil die
form immer gleich ist immer hohen und
klein manchmal offen blech habe ich mir
was speziell für den ramadan überlegt
nämlich machen wir eine mondsichel und
dafür braucht ihr auch gar keine
spezielle mondsichel backform das zeige
ich euch gleich alles und hier sind die
zutaten die sind auch sehr überschaubar
wir brauchen zu aller erst mal diese ktf
eben die sind erst mal geschmacksneutral
kommt als später durch den sirup erst
dafür benötigen wir butter die habe ich
nämlich quelle geschmolzen
hier sind die zutaten für den
zuckersirup ganz einfach wasser zucker
orangenblüten wasser und ein spritzer
zitronensaft und als käse nämlich im
mozzarella in scheiben geschnitten und
schön aus gewaschen damit sie nicht mehr
salzig schmeckt so wir beginnen jetzt
zuallererst mit den teig fäden die
bekommt er ja so schon fertig vakuumiert
und die sind jetzt erstmal ziemlich lang
jetzt nehme ich mir mein messer und
schneidet die erst mal so ganz grob
durch und dann rufe ich sie mit den
händen auseinander
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich ja so ein bisschen
auseinander gerückt weil ab und zu
kleben die aneinander
und um das zu vermeiden dem einfach die
hände benutzen und ich habe ja die
butter geschmolzen und die geben wir
jetzt mit dazu ich behalte allerdings
ungefähr zwei esslöffel für die form
beiseite denn damit hätten wir sie
gleich
[Musik]
so das wäre vorbereitet das gibt jetzt
ganz kurz an die seite es geht auch
sofort weiter ich zeige euch nämlich
jetzt wie er eine mondsichel form
hinbekommt ganz easy ihr nehmt euch
einfach eine springform ich habe jetzt
die hier die hat einen durchmesser von
24 cm und dann nehme ich mir noch einen
tortenring das gute ist der ist ja
verstellbar ihr könnt jetzt alternativ
auch einen teller neben der dreh zu
beständiger sind in den ofen packen
könnte aber ich habe jetzt den genommen
habe ich auf 16 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und gebt den hier einfach
rein und dann entsteht schon die
mondsichel form und ihr könnt jetzt hier
das ganze schön fetten damit wir das
auch machen richtig schön raus bekommt
und da habe ich ja die butter nicht
geschmolzen hab einfach mit einem pinsel
auftragen
die form ist jetzt vorbereitet und jetzt
kann auch schon unser kader freien ich
nehme da exakt die hälfte gibt es schön
an den boden und drückt das auch noch an
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass ihr euer da bricht die
schönste fest antritt mit den fingern
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch ein mozzarella
den habt ihr schon ausgewaschen dann
schmeckt er auch gar nicht mehr salzig
und dann ist dieses zusammenspiel
zwischen teig fäden mozzarella und
zuckersirup einfach richtig lecker und
den mozzarella gibt die jetzt so auf die
auf den cut dass es nicht ganz am rand
ist also lasst ihr euch und halben
zentimeter platz
und jetzt schnappt ihr euch die andere
hälfte des kaders und gibt es einfach
oben drüber und dann noch mal richtig
schön flach andrücken
[Musik]
so sieht die mondsichel jetzt aus ich
finde sie jetzt schon wunderschön obwohl
noch alles so ist wie schön ist es dann
erst nach dem backen das zeigt sich
gleich ich habe den ofen schon als
vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober unterhitze
und ich sage euch dann nach dem backen
wie lange das ganze gedauert hat wir
nutzen jetzt die backzeit und bereiten
unseren zuckersirup dann kann es schön
auskühlen dann muss jetzt nicht richtig
eisig kalt sein wenn es aus dem ofen
kommen aber besser ist es wenn er schon
aus führt immer noch lauwarm ist dafür
gebe ich jetzt zucker und wasser in
meinem kopf dass das kann zu aufkochen
und da könnt ihr auch schon so ein klein
spritzer orangenblüten wasser hinzugeben
das ist so typisch orientalische ihr
müsst einfach mal aus kübeln falls es
noch nicht ausprobiert hat
[Musik]
so das ganze darf jetzt drei minuten
lang kochen und er gibt auf jeden fall
noch zitronen sagt mit dazu das ist ganz
wichtig wegen den zuckerkristalle könnte
einfach mal nach gefühl schauen ich
nehme mal so eine viertel zitrone oder
das gut um und dann ist er fertig und
wenn es mir nur noch ein wenig auskennen
an der seite
[Musik]
und fertig schaut euch mal an wie hübsch
das aussieht richtig schön goldbraun
also hier oben schön knusprig die seiten
wenn man es gleich anheben sind bisschen
schön goldbraun und dann kann man das
ganze richtig hübsch servieren
ich habe das jetzt für 37 minuten im
ofen gehabt jeder ofenbank anders schaut
so nach 33 minuten mal nach dass mich zu
dunkel wird und ich freue mich jetzt auf
jeden fall das ganze zu servieren
wenn ihr das gut eingefettet habt dann
könnt ihr auch hier den tortenring jetzt
ganz einfach annehmen ohne dass sich da
was anklebt hat gut geklappt und als
nächstes nehme ich hier den spring vom
rand einmal weg dann schnappt ihr euch
einen retter oder meinem von einem cache
bord und schiebt das auf eure
servierplatten
[Musik]
und jetzt fehlt nur noch so ein bisschen
deko wobei ganz ehrlich das ist so schon
wunderschön aber so ein bisschen
farbklecks gehört für mich noch dazu und
das in form von pistazien was das ist
besser als pistazien richtig schön grün
richtig schön grob gehackt obendrauf und
was ihr auch noch selber entscheiden
könnt ist macht ihn den zuckersirup ich
jetzt drauf also jetzt muss noch heißen
schön drauf machen
oder reicht ihr das dann immer am tisch
dann kann jeder selbst entscheiden sich
die zuckersirup er haben möchte
aber ich kann mich jetzt ist meine
pistazien ja meine pistazien gibt auch
in unserem shop diesen frisch aus
gaziantep aus der türkei und die hab ich
jetzt erstmal schön groß
[Musik]
ich weiß genau was ihr jetzt denkt kiki
das muss sich nachmachen und ja das
müsst ihr unbedingt nachmachen
hier unten in der video beschreibung
schreibe ich euch die ganz genauen
mengenangaben geht schnell einkaufen
macht es nach und zeigt mir eure fotos
mit dem hashtag ins kittchen auch
instagram und facebook dann schauen sie
mal an und freue mich richtig fragt den
hammer
ich freue mich übertrieben wenn ich
fotos von euch auf instagram und
facebook sehr bestimmt denn der habe nur
bestätigen
jetzt wird sich natürlich ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken und beim
probieren und wir sehen uns ja dann
hoffentlich auch bei meinem nächsten
video was er dann schon bald kommt und
ihr solltet unbedingt mein kann
kostenlos abonnieren ein deutlicher nach
oben lassen und mir die kommentare
einfügen
warum wir haben fast immer ein ständchen
[Musik]
ok nehmen wir nicht an bord
also vorab natürlich eine dattel machst
du immer so ich wollte mich noch
verabschieden das habe ich somit getan
und wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
und wir sehen uns im nächsten video
teams
[Musik]